hey guys welcome back to the evan and
katelyn podcast the podcast where today
we are spilling
the beans but no one ever talks about
what you're spilling beans onto
we're gonna be spilling beans on top of
our sponsors kind of a weird
a weird visual hope they like beans
so we put out a uh um question on
a lot of our social media platforms to
get questions
that you guys have about sponsors and we
want to talk about this because it's a
huge part of our life and it seems like
like not many people share
the behind the scenes of the sponsors
and yeah
after over 250 sponsor deals i feel like
we're in a pretty good
position to like share some of the
inside beans
that's a lot of sponsor deals so it is
technically 250 individual
things but that sounds weird because we
don't have 250 videos on our main
channel
but uh we'll get into that later yeah
yeah
um so should we just jump right into the
q and a's or do you want to
give me a background on sponsors um
okay well i can give a very very brief
background
on sponsors basically uh i mean most
people probably
already know this but just kind of what
the basics of a sponsorship
deal is in case anyone is coming in more
new to this but it's basically where we
partner
specifically with a brand and negotiate
typically for us
a 60-second mid-roll where
we go through some talking points you
know
ask viewers to go to a certain website
or use a certain code
the sponsor pays us to do that segment
and that's kind of
the transaction yeah very very much
simplified down there's a lot that goes
into it there's a lot
there's a lot more than we have we've
spent six months negotiating a contract
before and we have spent
three days and all the the back and
forth of brainstorming ideas
coming up with mock-ups um writing
scripts
and yeah it's um it's an interesting
thing because
like you know youtube sponsorships
have not been a thing for that many
years if you think about it and so
it's very much wild west there are no
set rules everybody does it different
and we're all making it up
yeah we're all making up we're making it
up the brands are making it up
everyone's making it up and everyone has
a very different process
so it's a kind of a crazy it's crazy
waters to
navigate yeah all right so the first
question comes from our youtube
community eric
and send when did you get your first
volunteer and what was it was there a
certain
subscriber or view minimum to be
sponsored so
there is no subscriber or minimum view
to be sponsored really
it's as soon as you can like you know
there are no rules you know so if you're
like
and the smaller niche you're in it's
almost kind of
easier to get a sponsor in that niche it
also kind of depends on your niche like
we
came up in the maker community and it's
very common in the maker community for
everybody to have
sponsors and typically not not always
but
often that's because tool companies will
sponsor with this
this niche community but then that means
the audience is used to
seeing sponsorship so it wasn't it was
just kind of like a given to us that we
would do sponsorships because
all the people we were watching were
doing sponsorships so we started very
early our first sponsorship
was well i think we i i we haven't
looked through all of the ndas we've
signed all of the contracts we've signed
so we're going to kind of generalize
companies
yeah we're not going to say brand names
i mean well actually we we we can
because like in certain instances if
we're just saying
like if we're not giving away specifics
like we can say that we worked with a
brand but we don't want to tie specific
brands
to a certain price or something like
that prices
and stuff yeah because of ndas yeah so
we'll speak about them like
generally generally yeah yeah just like
this that's not something
it's a thought that i had before this
podcast i didn't really share with you
yeah no i'm uh i'm glad you stopped
because i was about to be like yeah
so um let's just say that we were
reached out to buy
a uh stock
company that sells stock assets
and um we had 30 000 subscribers
almost three years ago uh that's crazy
to think of
and we were only getting about uh 13
000 views in the first 30 days
of the video then and we got paid three
hundred dollars
and uh it's interesting because like
thirteen thousand views
is uh yeah thirteen thousand yeah
thirteen thousand views thirty thousand
subs that's
not we weren't a huge channel when we
started
doing this our thought was that it was
easier or it would be better to
like learn the ropes when we were small
that way if there was any
stumbling blocks like there wasn't a ton
of money on the line
there wasn't like we didn't have a huge
audience to mess up in front of
if we messed up you know yeah and and
the the the whole thing that's kind of
crazy about youtube
is the same amount of work that went
into this video that we got paid 300
for we are getting paid a lot more for
now it's like the
the same amount of time went into it but
since we've grown
our audience and our reach and i think
made our videos better
um like the same amount of time leads to
more profit and and there aren't that
many
businesses and industries where that's
possible yeah because typically like if
you're
in a you know if you work in an office
or you work wherever
if you want a raise you have to like
switch positions
to something where you're taking on more
responsibilities yeah and i will say we
have more responsibilities now but it's
not tied
to our income it's tied to the fact that
we've like expanded in a bunch of ways
yeah another really interesting data
point it looks back at the
the data on this video that was
sponsored for 300
and like you think okay you spent like
how many days working on that like a
week and you got paid 300
like is that viable at all but at that
time
in the first 30 days of that public of
publishing that video
the other way most youtubers get income
is from ads that run before your video
and pop-ups and stuff that's
called adsense that's a youtube product
and in 30 days we got paid
20 dollars and guess how much we've
gotten paid
on that video in adsense since then in
total
three years of that video being live
171.
so even though that sponsorship was very
small because
we were a very small channel it was
still it still made more money than the
adsense
yeah even over three years and that's
why sponsors are such
an important part of youtubers income
sources because
it lets them go full time so much
earlier i mean
that's 20 to 300 that ratio is just
a lot and it does get better like as
youtube understands your channel more
and knows how to like sell ads on your
channel and all of that
your your your cost per thousand um
views that that youtube pays you um it's
like called your rpm or your cpm or
something like that
that goes up so it does get better as
you keep on doing it yeah
it does get better but yeah i think that
answers that was a long answer to that
question
yeah but i think it also helps kind of
give some background
yeah so and and just to further expand
on that when we were at
30 000 subscribers um that was our first
sponsor
and then we started sprinkling them in
and they kind of came in waves and
batches
as like we figured out how to do
sponsored deals but by
80 000 subscribers or so pretty much
every video was sponsored and that's
what allowed us to go full-time
without that oh yeah if we were just
getting
adsense no way could we full time no way
no way
yeah all right next question caitlin
okay
um this is from twitter um itchy gamer
asks getting started how would you
recommend someone start networking slash
contacting sponsors
is there a website you'd recommend that
has links contacts resources
um so i think there's a couple
couple different ways um and we go into
this
more in our video uh how to start grow
and monetize the youtube channel how to
start grow and monetize your youtube
channel
but it's a mixture of people contacting
us and us contacting companies directly
and
yeah uh these days we don't really
contact them directly
um just because we have existing
relationships and
we get sponsorships via those existing
relationships but in the beginning we
would like dm them on instagram
or like try to find a marketing person
email on their website
it was kind of like cold there's
definitely a period where about half of
our sponsorships
were due to our own efforts and reaching
out
and all of that but um definitely having
a little bit of a portfolio of sponsored
deals
helps so in the beginning like if you
are thinking about starting a youtube
channel just
doing a sponsored deal and making it
work
well for everyone like you know for you
your viewers and the sponsor
proving that you can do that will help
you get more so the more you do yeah the
more you get
which is again why i like i'm glad we
started when we were small because we
were a small risk
for the company um and
even though we didn't have any any past
sponsorships
like it was okay because we were a small
risk if you start doing sponsorships
when you know you're getting 500 000
views on every single video that's going
to cost a lot more to a company if you
ask for a fair price and that's going to
be a bigger risk for them if you don't
have any past sponsorships
so yeah um and we got one more question
from twitter hunter crumpley how does
like sponsorships
change now versus when we started that
i'm yeah i think the main thing that's
changed is
more people are reaching out to us and
we have to filter out a lot more
but also the relationships that we made
when we were first growing have stayed
and those relationships have been so
important i mean like
like knowing someone them trusting you
you trusting them
like having that for the long term is
really important and we have some
companies that we've worked with for
like two years two years now
maybe more yeah hi baby you want to hop
up we're talking about sponsorships
the supervisors has done a walk by
blessing
yeah thank you for blessing the podcast
with your presence all right from
twitter bella what makes you feel most
limited by working with sponsors and
conversely what about sponsorships
is the most freeing so i think in terms
of
limited it's time pressure by
committing to doing a
video in a certain month usually it's a
certain month some sponsors want it in
the first half of the month
some want it on like a specific week and
so
committing to that can be kind of
limiting because then if
something comes up or your schedule's
super crazy you can't just say like oh
instead of doing three
videos this month we'll do two yeah you
just can't do that a behind-the-scenes
peek
at the curtain you know we book far out
um just for our own planning purposes so
like our schedule is locked like we have
a certain number of videos that we
need to make and we have committed to
that and we want to make them all
winners
and if we go through live things or
whatever
we can't adjust that schedule that
easily because
we've never on our end we have never
pulled out from any
sponsors right i mean we've pulled out
during preliminary talks
yeah yeah yeah but once like a contract
is signed
yeah like i don't think anything has
ever thrown that off on our
end things have gone wrong things have
gone wrong
like disagreements on on both end but
we've never just been like
hey guys we're out yeah you know yeah um
it's because we want to establish those
long-term relationships we want to
establish trust
yeah yeah and you know like when you're
with us
big company with redundancy in it you
know
like committing to a schedule getting
that locked in that makes sense that's
really good
and it all works because like if you
need to step away for a little bit
someone can kind of step in you're not
talking about sponsorship so you're just
talking about working
if you are working at a big company in
general yeah as redundancy
yeah but like you know i i know a lot of
youtubers try not to schedule that far
out because they don't know what videos
they're doing and they don't know like
what their schedule is going to be we do
and that kind of takes us to
a positive is like the thing that's
freeing about sponsorships is we know
that we have income for the next
certain number of months that we have
booked because with adsense going up and
down and
you know there have been multiple waves
of demonetization that's happened
um and like you know one time like
patreon had a controversy and people
pulled out a patreon
like no single income source that is
not from sponsors is as guaranteed as
sponsors because
uh at the same time we've never backed
out
from a deal that like was really going i
don't think we've ever had a sponsorship
that has not paid us
oh well they've always paid us we did
have one back out in the 11th hour
after the video was
oh my gosh that was a nightmare our
biggest sponsor ever
our biggest one a big ambitious project
that took like
oh it took place over a month
and yeah they pulled out last minute
because
of third like you know nothing
in our control all because there were
like four companies involved us
an agency an agency and a company yeah
and
so many lawyers
and and in the end just a lot lost in
communication
yeah i think the biggest thing is the
company didn't really know what they
wanted
and we kind of did what they asked and
then they're like i don't know if that's
what we wanted
and then they were like bye
um oh yeah so but but that's
pretty rare that's what happens yeah um
but yeah i think that kind of
covers some of the like the main
pros and cons i mean like the other
limiting thing is it's just how
long it takes to do sponsored deals
sometimes
and i think that's one reason we often
will do
recurring like we'll work with the same
companies over and over again because
it's it's a lot faster yeah you know
every time
you are doing something with a whole new
brand or a whole new agency
there's so much more onboarding and you
don't really know exactly what they're
expecting and they don't really know
what to expect from you and there's so
many more
phone calls and zooming more contracts
contracts you know yeah so so generally
i can walk through like the process just
really high level really quick
so you establish a relationship with a
company you reach out or they reach out
usually you kind of run down through a
brief you
like kind of agree on a general price
and then a contract is sent
then you negotiate that contract and
then
you know the video pictures go back and
forth and then we
write a script or whatever sometimes we
send it to them sometimes we don't it
depends on all the agreements
and then um sometimes they need to
review it beforehand
most of the times they do they always
need to review it yeah we have to send
them either just the ad or the whole
video depending on the contract and the
price and everything
and then they need to approve it before
we go live
and one of the things that's been so
stressful for us
is many times like you might you guys
might notice that like we published a
little bit late
on friday it's because at 10 00 a.m
on friday we've gotten approval to go
live and then we go live but like
friday morning we wake up and we don't
even know if our video is approved to be
published
that's happened at least
four five six but i will see the
majority of the time
it's a much simpler process because it's
more like
we've established a six month once a
month deal with a brand
and we don't have to send them a script
beforehand
they don't care what the project is at
all
we send them the ad to review a couple
days before it goes live and we usually
hear within 24 hours
that we're good to go with no changes
yeah those are our favorite sponsors
and like that's again that's why you see
us working with the same companies over
and over
again sometimes i think we got that
question from somewhere somewhere yeah
yeah i think that is a question from
later
that's why we like these companies i
think the biggest reason why we can do
that with some companies
is because they trust us yeah they know
that we're going to like
do our best to make a funny ad that
people will want to watch and
that that that hits the points that they
want and and that's
what's so good about forming those
long-term relationships yeah
all right okay um here's a question um
about some legal stuff
so from kindred fiore how did you deal
with the legal part
um you had to ask a lawyer first for
tips and red flags you had to be aware
about
um so typically we don't involve a
lawyer
we've gotten pretty dang good at
reviewing contracts by this point
and typically there's a lot of the same
stuff and we kind of
know the red flags to look out for and
again
i'm glad we started when there wasn't
that much on the line
yeah um because now when we're dealing
with higher amounts than we were back
then
we are more confident in reviewing
contracts or like asking for changes and
things like that
yeah yeah almost everything is up to
negotiation and if
it isn't then that might be a sign of
something you know
um but yeah we we i think i did go talk
to a lawyer once
um about something i think i did like a
free consult and i got like
no value out of it oh i think it was
like we were thinking about
doing because some companies have
contracts but then some smaller
companies it's just like
an email and so we were like oh should
we make our own contract
for these other contracts companies just
kind of something
very generic but so we can still have
something signed and i think that's why
you went to the lawyer just
to be like how do i draft this yeah i
forget
yeah it was a long time ago um but yeah
we don't have an aid
like we don't have an agent that
represents us we do work with agencies
that represent brands
but we don't have like our agent we call
up or we also don't have a manager
that we call up we really don't have any
company yeah it's like we really don't
have any interest in that i don't
we like being in full control even
though that's a lot for us to handle
but we've been doing it for so long now
that like you know i can see the value
in it if like
you blow up all of a sudden and you're
like i don't know how to do any of this
stuff
i'm like leaving opportunities on the
table i need help but like
we've been doing it for so long it's you
know
we already know how to do everything we
already have relationships established
all right real quick question that we
can address from youtube tech by matt
how is your business set up
partnership llc s corp is financial
independence or early retirement
something you guys are interested in
striving towards
yeah so we're we are um
in transition well no i think we're
officially
transitioned to an s corp that's corp
yeah caitlin started
uh an llc for herself a while ago i
joined in and then we transitioned to an
s corp
so like you know that's where we're at
very interesting but i think like you
should establish an official business
you need to have an official business
it's not hard to set up an llc
i did it like i was didn't really know
anything about it and i was able to do
it i was like
20 21 when i did it um
and uh in terms of financial
independence early retirement that is
something that we
do want to strive towards but we're just
going to keep on making youtube videos
yeah we want to strive towards it for a
like
oh we don't have to
worry about things so much but not from
a we don't want to work
anymore yeah it's more like we're going
to be more immune to seeing that our
video
is performing 10 out of 10 of the last
like and maybe we won't have to
we won't feel like we have to have a
sponsor on every video eventually
yeah but it is kind of like you know i
think that that um i'm going to kind of
maybe jump ahead
here um a little bit but i think that
someone asked
um uh from twitter bella was there any
was there ever any time you guys worried
you wouldn't be able to create a
sustainable income out of youtube making
streaming
i'm curious about how how uh any rough
hatches and how you got through them
so before we started we saved up enough
money
because we are planners and you know
warriors a certain degree and we we had
saved up enough money
so that we could you know make a go at
this
and have some cash reserves to pull from
if we needed to
we ended up doing okay it didn't drop
too much
and then we you know we we grew that but
um
yeah there were some worries that we
were going to make it in the beginning
and i think that
even for like maybe two years even after
we had gotten successful even after we
had gone over
100k subscribers and every video was
sponsored we did worry like
how long is this youtube channel going
to last how long are people still going
to be interested
in our channel and
um you know is the youtube bubble gonna
pop or what what have you you know
because
it's still such a new industry i mean
you know we we've been doing
this for three years which seems like
short for a career but also it's like
the whole career you know people have
probably been doing youtube for 10 years
but it really started taking off
as a financially viable option for many
people i'd say only like
five or six years ago something like
that
i mean i feel like that's the point
where it was more common knowledge that
you could
make a career out of it i think people
were doing it before that it just wasn't
as common
yeah but i think that that the thing
that made us feel more confident
um is being able to diversify from
one channel into the gaming channel and
then
into other platforms like tick tock and
what have you
and knowing that even if one platform
goes away our community will still have
our backs
and we'll kind of support us wherever we
kind of need to go
to a certain degree and then we can
rebuild
their worst case scenario that's kind of
like getting off topic though i think to
bring it back to sponsors
uh yeah like um again we have
more control over our future when we are
working with sponsors we
we feel like because we can like lock
things in and know at least like a few
months ahead of time
what's coming down the pipe yeah
speaking of
you know being in control of setting up
sponsors or
maybe good transition we got a few
questions about um what percent of
sponsors do we turn down and how do we
do it and everything so
from the youtube community uh catherine
neal asks
how can you tell which sponsors are real
and which are fake
when they call when you are contacted by
email
i've heard some other youtubers mention
that they get a lot of spam do you have
an
agent that you work with or how does
that contact part
at all work in general so i mean i think
the easiest way to tell when things are
fake
are just like either when they're super
super generic
or dear evan and katelyn with no spaces
i'm really interested in your content i
think that you have a beautiful
family and i think your content is
beautiful
yeah we got one that was like i love
your family it's just so beautiful
and we're like are you talking about our
cat she is beautiful
um or like you know you can really tell
when it's generic
or sometimes it's like a formatted html
based
email where it's like obviously someone
writing an email
individually to creators is not going to
like format it like that
or like click here on this survey to
submit your interest in this sponsorship
or something like that it's like
you can tell just by glancing at them
and i think that like
some people go with management companies
to offload
like all of that contact email that you
get
but honestly like sorting through the
the
the spammy stuff takes like minutes each
morning even though it's a lot i'm like
spam spam sanitary samsung's vampire
spam and there's certain things that
like
you know they may may or may not be
actual spam but we're just gonna say no
to like if someone
wants to wants us to review their
product
it's a no yeah you know like there's
just certain like we don't do reviews um
and honestly like i i feel weird saying
this but like as we've grown as a
channel
i can kind of tell if a company might
have the budget
yeah you know for a sponsorship right
off the bat or like if they're
experienced with
sponsorships um in general like if we've
seen a brand
do lots of brand deals all over the
place we're honestly more likely to work
with them because they know
how to work with youtubers yeah
yeah and and we know it's going to be an
easier less stressful
yeah burden upon us we kind of see red
flags when it
like we can tell that they are new to
this space because that means
like we're going to have to hold their
hand and we're going to have to try
extra hard to convince them
to pay us our rate or like they're gonna
want
more control than we normally give yeah
over like editorial
stuff you know so yeah we've gotten
uh an email from or a question from uh
youtube823 what's the shadiest email you
receive from a
company um i feel like i should be
saving some of those and like we like we
read some out on a podcast at some point
because because it is pretty funny um uh
but yeah we have gotten uh emails from
all sorts of
companies like you know uh products that
we might not agree with um
products that we're not comfortable
advertising um products that
you know
yeah every variety so we we we probably
turned down
i don't know 90. yeah 90
of the emails that we get i mean yeah if
you're counting like the spam
we're counting the spam ones okay if
we're granting the spam once that's 90
but like
if you filter out all of the spam ones
even like the deals that might be legit
that are for more serious amounts of
money um and more serious companies
probably like 50 percent yeah
50 and i think that's a tough thing that
we've struggled with too it's like
we could make more money just by working
more i mean that that's
something that i think maybe all
youtubers struggle with not not even
just responding like you're in control
of your own
knob you can turn it up or you can turn
it down and we've been trying to turn it
down
little by little like earlier this year
um
we were only publishing a video every
other week
and that was great but we've since kind
of
turned on multiple where we do four in a
row yeah and
did we do five in a row a little bit ago
yeah we did five five
are we still in the five in a row i
don't know i don't know i mean
like it's one of those things that like
we pay attention to a lot more than
anyone else probably
notices um but uh
anyways yeah that it it can be hard to
say no because you're like
well there's an extra friday in this
month well but also it's like
oh this company might be cool what if we
like if we say no will they ever come to
us again and sometimes
if we if you say if someone comes to you
you say no they may never come to you
again
honestly that's probably been the thing
that has made us say yes when we felt
like
we maybe would struggle to squeeze them
in
like it's more about establishing that
relationship
for the long term not about that
specific deal it's like oh
this agency works with some really cool
brands or like
this brand is so cool like we actually
legit use this brand and
like we were fans of this brand long
before the sponsorship this is the
perfect fit
but you know we don't have time to our
schedule's full you know
yeah and we try to like schedule them in
yeah but also it's like
sometimes some companies have a budget
for a quarter or a month or what have
you and
they may not know if they have budget in
the future and and what have you so
sometimes it is like here's your chance
do you take it or leave it
yeah or sometimes someone will come
expressing interest
and you might not have anything in your
schedule for the next two months but
then negotiations take six months and
you're like well
glad i said yes back then because it's
finally coming to fruition
yeah much later yeah and uh
see i think the biggest reason why we
turn sponsors down is because we have
too many deals coming our way which is a
very lucky position to be in i feel very
lucky and blessed to to be in that place
um
but also i mean like we a strong
criteria is how good of a fit it is for
us how easily can we recommend it you
know if if it's uh
like you know there's a ton of
things we've turned down for various
reasons but if it's not something we
feel
comfortable promoting or if it's not a
product that we believe in
or if it's something that we're like
[Music]
that's that's another reason why i like
sometimes we'll turn down a deal that's
for more money for something that we
feel that we can recommend more
but you know another thing that happens
i think that's kind of like
an obvious and an obvious thing that
people would expect
you know hopefully people expect you to
turn down deals for products that you're
not comfortable with but
i think a slightly more behind the
scenes reason that
we very frequently will turn down deals
is they
want too much editorial input yes
sometimes
just on the ad but sometimes on the
whole video
you know if someone wants an integration
that's more than like a minute to a
minute and a half
that's a no like like we're not gonna do
that
if someone is not cool with us
being humorous in the ad that's a no if
someone wants to
dictate an entire video or have their
hands too much in the project
that's a no and we've even like we've
had sponsors where
we worked with them and they were like
pretty hands-off in the beginning and
then they got more and more
hands in the pot and we stopped with
them yeah
even though even if we liked the product
yeah
because we just don't want that level of
editorial input like when they're
giving us input on the aesthetics of our
project
and they want us to change the
aesthetics the aesthetics of the project
because they like a different aesthetic
more no
that has nothing to do with your
sponsorship
you know we value our freedom the most
yeah and and and also it's like not just
like our freedom to create
projects that we enjoy the most but also
like
you know if you get locked in to do a
specific project on a specific
day that's the most stressful yeah what
if that takes longer or something is
delayed or whatever like
like if if the sponsor isn't tied to a
specific concept
oftentimes we'll swap concepts around
because we just did a switcheroo for
later
this month yeah like one thing that is
done earlier than the other or
like something is a delayed or the you
know we need to
re do something i mean having the
freedom to swap
sponsors around from video to video is
huge so like 90
of our sponsors they don't care what
video they're on
they don't need to hear the concept
beforehand they
they just trust that we're going to do
something generally ad friendly
we have formed those relationships in
those ways
no but usually those brands started out
that way too yeah and it just happens to
be the brands that
you see working with a lot of youtubers
and i think it's just like
they trust like they see the value in
just letting the youtuber
make a video that they think will work
well on their channel yeah that's great
you know so even though they were new to
us it's like they saw that our
videos performed well or they thought we
would be a good fit or
whatever and they just kind of trusted
us so from uh the youtube community
paige hammer
last question on like you know turning
down sponsors or saying yes to sponsors
have you ever regretted any sponsors you
said yes to
i think there have been sponsors that
ended up
so just like the um example i said where
um a sponsor ended up
becoming needier and needier and wanting
more and more input i don't necessarily
regret saying yes to them
but i felt like we kind of pulled out at
the right time
so that's kind of a different thing i
think the only one that i
do regret is the one that pulled out at
the last minute
yeah yeah well there should have been
like like knowing what we know now we
should have asked more questions like
has this brand ever worked with
influencers before like
and we were getting red flags right off
the bat like in the picture says like
don't be too humorous don't be too silly
and we're like we're humorous and silly
are you okay are you okay with that and
then like
they sent back like you guys were too
like
well and they said they said yes we're
okay with that and then at the end
once everything was done they were like
this is too frivolous frivolous
have you watched our videos yeah we are
kind of frivolous
i would say that's the only one i i
regret and it's
like i'm still very happy with the video
i'm so glad we did the project but it
would have been a much
like we were so stressed we were
ordering
we had to order so much equipment we
spent so much money we wasted so much
money we wasted so much additional money
just because like we were sleepless
nights
we were ordering everything one day
shipping and we had to order like
multiple options and a lot of the stuff
we can't return we had to do rushed
rentals we did all this rush
we were ready and then we had to delay
the publishing of the video like two or
three weeks
so that they could review so it was a
huge rush to get it done on time which
made it a lot more stressful than it had
to be and then there was like this huge
weight during the review period i think
we told our patreons more patreon yeah
um but i would say that's the only one
that i regret but at the same time like
we
learned a lot and we have applied that
knowledge to oh hello do you want to
join
we have applied that knowledge to future
sponsorships and like
learned things but in terms of like any
sponsors that we like right
oh we shouldn't have recommended that no
no we we do all that
pre-thought beforehand yeah and we have
we're lucky enough to like have enough
coming our way that we like
and say no to to well in any ways if we
didn't feel good about it we just
wouldn't have no sponsor
yeah i mean we and we've had videos
where like we sponsored ourselves i
think there's only been like two this
year where we're like
this is brought to you by our patreon
brought to you by evan and caitlin march
yeah shopify katelyn.com um
yeah yeah i think that's that covers
that topic okay we have
some questions about logistics from the
youtube community naomi
firstner what's the difference between
sponsoring a video and sponsoring a
portion of a video
why do you sometimes put tapes over
brands and videos like the rainbow bench
and other times you don't do you always
try the product you're sponsoring
beforehand sorry i put a lot of
questions wow yeah so well
i pulled i pulled this because
especially the first
two questions there was some um like
comments under this with people kind of
guessing and speculating
and so i thought it'd be an interesting
one to clear up because um
uh most people actually in the comments
didn't get it right
okay so sponsoring a video and
sponsoring a portion of a video
okay so um most brands we work with
don't differentiate like sponsoring a
video
it's just sponsoring a video like it's
technically
they're um getting a bracketed
60-second segment and they don't really
care about the rest so it's kind of like
them sponsoring a video but they don't
really care about the
um oh i'm blanking on they don't care
about like the words
we use to describe that sponsorship they
just call it sponsoring a video
some of the bigger brands that have
bigger
i'm assuming lawyers teams yeah and
things like that are
very particular about if they are
sponsoring the entire video
or just a portion of it so if you hear
us say
like in our recent video you know the
brand sponsors
this portion of the video that means
they're not like
they they don't have like a claim on the
rest of it so
if you know it makes it like less less
like less
risk for them less worries of
third-party ip less worries about
like things showing up in the video or
things that we do
or what have you you know because i
think that like like we said
since this is the wild wild west and
since these videos are up forever
kind of linking us to these brands and
since the ftc
hasn't really gotten their act together
when it comes to youtube
and roles are still often changing rules
are still often changing oftentimes
like certain brands will want to be
extra
play it extra safe play it extra safe um
so
if we say if we say it one way or
another we're kind of just following the
lead
of the sponsor who's sponsoring us yeah
and we're kind of like
you know acclimating to them and i think
that like
you know i think that we have done
everything as above the board as
possible and you know following all of
the latest guidelines but
it is changing and some people try to
like future proof things
in certain ways but it's all gases yeah
and that's the same reason why there's
often tape over our brands because and
it's not because like
a brand is like i'm paying for this
sponsorship i don't want you showing off
this other brand no no
it's it's actually because that logo
is ip third-party ip that belongs to a
different company yeah and to play it
safe legally the brand paying us
doesn't want to be showing third-party
ip in the same way they don't want us to
show like
a spongebob time card saying 12 seconds
later
well like you know it's the same reason
why like in tv shows
you might notice that there's never an
apple logo on a laptop yeah you'll
notice that everything is genericized
you'll notice that like
so many things are covered and people
wear t-shirts that are unbranded
or like fit you know made up for that tv
show or whatever we have to wear
unbranded t-shirts if it's not our own
we can wear our own t-shirts because
those designs belong to us but i'm just
wearing a like a
blue t-shirt because but like we
couldn't wear a shirt with
a nike logo on it and some people have
noticed that in some videos i've had to
blur the adidas logo on my pink slides
it's because it's third-party ip and
legally
the brand paying us wants to play it
safe yeah and then usually
we just end up leaving the tape because
like there's no point in taking all off
and then having to put it
all on again the next time a brand wants
to play it safe and some brands
again everyone has like a different
level of how safe they want to play it
some brands are a little bit more lacks
about it but um
yeah and so sometimes we have had a
brand sponsor
the whole video where like we we we
intro it is sponsored we do the
sponsored ad and then at the end we
thank them again
that's a fully sponsored video in the
mind of the people who sponsored it
so for that entire video we needed to be
super strict about
third party ip cause like then you know
like
you know anyone can sue anyone for
anything at any time
but it's more likely that like if you
know
brand a is getting you know uh
monetary benefit from us using another
brand's
product then like i don't know what what
what legal things might happen yeah so
that's it again so it's all
yeah and then um do you always try the
products you're sponsoring beforehand
often we do um like i'll download or
install it or
all you know we'll buy it ourselves or
what have you they won't always send it
to you
beforehand sometimes we have to buy it
ourselves just to like play it safe yeah
and then you know oftentimes like i
think there's one brand where we said
like
okay if if you send it to us and we
don't like it are you okay with us
pulling out and they said okay yeah and
then they they send it to us yeah cause
like we're like can we get it beforehand
and they're like no they only send it to
you if you're doing the brand deal and
then so we're like okay but
if we don't like it we're going to back
up and we want to make sure you
understand that and you're okay with it
yeah and then they're like
understandable yeah and then we we liked
it and we're still using it
thankfully yeah um but we wouldn't like
try something we
we're always prepared or we have a way
to that if we don't like it
yeah we will like build that in we'll
build that in yeah i don't think that
there's
any product that we've tried and we
haven't enjoyed
i'm trying to remember i don't there are
oh there are multiple multiple things
where like they'll reach out to us
we'll research it look at the google
reviews look at the trusted pilot
and we're like your reviews aren't
better business guru and stuff like that
and
we're like hello
polite excuse to say no because we want
to be polite and business-like but also
no yeah yeah so that has happened but i
don't think we've ever gotten to the
point where they
sent it to us yeah or like we signed a
contract and then we didn't like it
i think anything like that we've figured
out before or like honestly there's one
product that they reached
out to us and um it got okay reviews
but like there were just so many
like better or ju like just the same
ones for like half the price or less
and i'm like we can't i can't i can't
recommend
that even that was actually something we
were in the market for but that's why
you knew about all the other options i
thought i bought the cheaper one
so funny but yeah yeah so we we we put a
lot of
so much time goes into the
behind-the-scenes stuff guys
i i don't i i i feel like
explaining it all would sound like
complaining but just know that we
there's a lot of time there's a lot and
we try to make them the best we can
speaking of which a question from laura
williams do your sponsors review your
ads before you can put them in a video
if so what is the review process like
so every sponsor wants to review
at least the ad portion have we talked
about product placement yet
no we haven't but we'll get to that
we'll we can we can talk about that
after this
yeah um so um
sponsors always want to review like the
60 second segment at least
which totally makes sense we're totally
fine with that they want to you know
they usually have a certain amount of
talking points
that they're cool with us fitting in
in a way that we want to fit in that
feels natural
um and that's that's typically how it is
usually there's like a handful of
talking points and a
call to action at the end we try to fit
it into like a skit or do something
funny
and then we send it to them and they
make sure like we hit the points that
they want to stay and
honestly typically how it works i think
the
most changes we've gotten back and the
thing that they're honestly looking most
for
is do we say something false like do we
over promise
or do we like like
yeah you know are we unintentionally
misleading
most of the brands that we work with
like
are kind of looking for red flags like
that and
they're totally cool with us
embellishing those talking points with
funniness or skits or silliness however
we want to do
and they're just like okay did they get
the was it did they say the right
percent off at the end because we
switched it and i just want to make sure
that they got the right one or like did
they have the text
overlay okay check or like you know we
we
say like you know oftentimes like with
more strict brands we'll send them what
we're generally gonna say and they're
like
actually can you change this word to
this word because like
that's more accurate in a way or
something like that i mean honestly
most most brand deals we do they're just
like
trying to help us say accurate and
correct things they i don't think we've
ever
gotten back saying that sounds dumb or
that's too silly or
something like that we haven't but we
also have gotten to the point where like
if a brand reaches out we'll say like
this is the style we do ads in see some
examples here
we often use skits or humor is that cool
and um so typically
these days we don't get to the point of
actually
sending them anything if if they're not
cool with that
but yeah some some brands do require to
see like a script for the ad beforehand
or some where we're just getting red
flags that they're going to be stricter
stricter or needier we'll write out a
script for the ad and send it to them so
we don't
waste time filming it editing it and
then they want us to change a bunch of
stuff
yeah and it really is in both of like
you know
when we can get to like that really nice
place with the brand
that's better for everyone less time on
them less time on us
faster back and forth everything there's
less overhead needed on their end the
less time needed on our end
and i think that's where everyone wants
to get but like i think like at the
beginning sometimes bands are like
which makes sense i mean we're new to
them and and um
oftentimes they do also want to review
the video too
um more recently now recently
like i think because of you know in the
past six months
a lot has happened in the world and they
want to make sure that like
we're being sensitive we're being
sensitive you know we're not saying
anything insanely controversial and so
they're looking for that
kind of stuff um they don't want to be
associated with
like someone who like goes off the rails
you know
yeah exactly which makes sense we've um
you know
so some companies previously didn't care
about reviewing the video at all and in
the past like six months
they do want to see it none of them have
ever
none of those more chill companies that
didn't even like care before have ever
had any changes
yeah in the video they just want to like
see it now
some of the bigger companies do
review the whole video and sometimes
we'll have specific
changes but usually it's only like
ftc related stuff like oh
um uh on your patreon shout out at the
end
instead of having the patreon logo on
there can you like
say thank you to our patrons
you know things like that where it's
like it's not about like
creative stuff mm-hmm it's more like
oh this might be like a slight red flag
for legal or whatever
yeah um and what's that review process
like it depends on the sponsor again
sometimes
super chill three day but like sometimes
it's
two weeks yeah it's usually either super
chill we hear back within 24 hours with
no changes
or it's like a huge two-week process
where we go through many many revisions
and phone calls like video cards
you know yeah video decks slides that's
a lot more rare
yeah um um okay so so one thing i'm not
sure if
we've got any questions did we get any
questions about uh product placement
no but that ties back to the thing we
said at the beginning about how we've
done 250 sponsorship deals
so um some of the sponsorships we do we
used to do them a lot more frequently
but we still do now
are product placements and there's
a lot less information about how to
properly
do that on youtube you know we try to
follow the best practices
that we can and we've recently even
started like
over communicating rather than under
communicating but like a product
placement
is where a brand is paying you to use
their
product but you're not endorsing it
verbally or doing talking points or
giving like a
call to action so like an example of
that is
like the resin company we work with like
we've been working with them for a bit
now a lot pretty long time
um and we make sure to show
the logo when we use them and we include
a link and say thank you for sponsoring
sometimes just like exclusivity too to a
certain degree
and like it's set up in so many
different ways yeah
it's that's even like more wild west
because i feel like it's less
common um and so that's
that's nice because like we don't have
to do talking points
you know we can give a link you know
say thank you to our sponsor and text um
it's a lot less
invasive and we can
layer it into other videos because um
you know a lot of sponsors don't want
you doing like two 60-second mid-rolls
they don't want you to like talk about
this company and another company
some some channels do that i mean i i've
seen i've seen some channels do like an
ad at the beginning and an ad at the end
yeah and i mean like if it's something
that like their audience is
is cool with then you know that's
totally fine um
for us it's easier just to limit it to
one
60 second mid-roll per perfect yeah
that's enough work
but we do have um one or two companies
that like
we'll use their products
as like a product placement yeah and
honestly one of the reasons why we've
stopped doing that as much
is because like again we want the
freedom
and the brands that we still do that
with are really flexible
and they understand that like dates
might move around or what have you and
they're cool with that
the brands that weren't cool with that
we just stopped doing it
yeah so there's only like two brands
that we still do that with on a
like you know and if we wanted to we
probably could reach out to more brands
establish those relationships
you know monetize more but i mean the
product placements it's
it's a small small fraction of the cost
of a normal sponsorship which makes
sense because like we're not
talking about it we're not doing any
talking points and the reason so it's
not really worth it to like
establish new relationships it's just
there's a couple companies that we
already have existing relationships with
yeah yeah so um let's see
uh i think we addressed a lot of the
things
um a lot of questions under the
logistics so let's maybe move to
creative control
yeah from naomi firster has a sponsor
ever refused one of your ideas
with something like feel your butt for
example
um so we've i don't think we've ever had
a sponsor just like flat out refuse
a skit idea um
i think i think this is this is where
the editorial and creative control
comes in we have had companies
refuse our project ideas
yes and they're saying like oh no that's
to
whatever um and usually we stop working
with them
that's true though that's true though um
but yeah i don't think that
anyone has ever said like i don't like
that ad
again typically like we've vetted
this company the best we can and made
sure they're cool with us being silly
they know our style
before we get to the point of filming an
ad for them
um a related question from mason masters
is do your sponsor say hey it'd be funny
if you dressed up as aliens and talk
about futuristic lasers or are you guys
just super creative we're just super
weird so that's referring to
the alien characters we have used in
several ads
um space does start us
um no that's just us we like coming up
with
funny characters um because i think it
it gives you a way to like explain the
talking
points in an ad but as a character which
makes it more
funny inherently every weird thing in an
ad has just been us we have no excuses
i like dressed up as carol baskin in an
ad and we're like hope they're cool with
this
well i think one time we pretended like
we were parachuting out of an
uh airplane and we're like falling
through the sky that was fun to film
that was really fun we did a lot of
greens yeah but i think that i don't
think that any company has ever come to
us with
creative direction on the ad itself no
never they're just like make sure to say
these words
generally but also in your own words
yeah and also like we've we've never
really
like we try to make the words our own
every single time
and i don't think we've ever had a
company saying actually no stick with
the script exactly how it is
and i mean it's a it's more benefit to
them if it sounds natural coming yeah
from you the only thing that is often
like strict is like this specific
offer at the end yeah because it might
be like if you say
go to url for 50 off your
um your entire order and they're like oh
actually it's not
it's you have to also do the code so
like you have to say
go to url and use this code to get 15
off your entire order but they're just
trying to help on accuracy
well i mean and that's just like we we
just did it wrong
you know what i mean that's the only
thing they've ever been specific about
yeah so that kind of answers a couple of
the questions so um
lei pacquette
leighton paquette asks what's the
average length of time you're expected
to hype the brand and do they provide
video footage for the spot or do you
have to capture your own we say no if
they want us to talk for over
like a minute or we would have people
say like
three minutes for five minutes
are you crazy do you want people to
click away
so our average is 60 seconds sometimes
it's a smidge more
sometimes it's a smidge and often times
they don't give a time
they're just like saying hit these
talking points and we make sure that we
can get
a funny thing and the talking points
within a reasonable amount of time which
is
like 30 to 60 seconds yeah and the only
times that they provide
video footage are um if there's you
know there is like a specific ui they
want to show and
you know then it's just like easier for
them to sh to
give us the footage of like click sign
up here
and here are the three plans we offer
you know it's like we would capture that
video footage
or they can send it to us which is much
easier and it's typically a very small
part
of the ad
you know like it's not like the whole ad
is that
ui it's just that like they want to show
a very specific like place to click
when you are saying how it works and
it's just easier if they send it to us
yeah um we got a question from beanie b
um uh is there anything that you like
are there any restrictions that you have
to follow like you can't say anything
bad about the product
there's an influencer once who got a
sponsorship but just talked how about
how terrible the product was
but the sponsor didn't mind since people
thought it was hilarious and it actually
got more attention than
expected i think like i wouldn't feel
comfortable
doing a sponsorship and then just
talking about how bad it was
i would rather just not do the
sponsorship because it would feel weird
to take a company's money and then just
talk crap about them yeah you know what
i mean i i don't
i don't think that i mean we re we read
through
them and there are some things like
you know we can't sue each other and you
know legal protections and all sorts of
things like that but
um i think that you know
we're supposed to generally present a
product and give our honest opinion
and we if we didn't like it we would
just say no from the beginning
it's also different because like a
sponsorship is different than a review
yeah and i think in a review process
there's more
of giving your own thoughts where like
it might be a mixture of like i really
like this but i didn't like this part
and
there's there's just more time
and and for you to give your thoughts on
various aspects of a product whereas
like
we're going through a 60-second thing
and it's more about like
telling you what the product is yeah
it's more telling what the product is
on like our feelings about it like
everything is just very condensed yeah
and i'm gonna try to give a very generic
example like let's say you're reviewing
a
cardboard box wow wow i tried to go very
generic
but like if we were promoting like this
specific cardboard box brand would just
say like hey you can get your cardboard
boxes here here are the good things
that they feel differentiate them from
the competition a cardboard box review
channel would be like
oh this cardboard box is great it's it's
it packs down well
but it's dual walled and that's good
this one
has waterproofing on it and this one
doesn't or whatever you know it's like
in a review you can go into the pluses
and minuses of this
verse that verse that whereas like in
most sponsors you just say like here's
the thing that's special or unique about
this brand
um yeah so it's like if you're being
paid to review something
i think that'd be really tricky yeah i
doubt i don't know how that would work
that's one reason we say no to reviews
well i mean also i just don't want to do
it i just don't want to do it yeah
um yeah i think that i kind of went a
little extra there
answering more than they asked okay so
this is something that we get asked a
lot
um uh what percentage of our income is
from what source
um and what percent so
um are you struggling with words here
i'll take over
maya ask what percentage of your income
is from sponsorship you can be as
general or specific
as you want yeah i think it's
interesting because we actually in an
earlier podcast
um from 2019 over a year ago from
june of 2019 we talked about this and we
looked up
our percentages today and they have
changed yeah so
um back in the day when we were smaller
60 of our income came from sponsors 15
from patreon 15 from adsense
six from affiliate and six from merch
when you say affiliate you mean
affiliate links affiliate link
yeah tools tools and what have you stuff
um
and i think that it's it's it's changed
a lot in very interesting ways and
we'll kind of break down maybe why and
how and stuff and again those first
numbers were from
june of 2019 which at the point of
recording this is like a year and a
couple months ago yeah
so um and also in that time we've
started gaming
which has added a whole another chunk um
so that's
that's why some of these have gone down
but now sponsors are
47 so from 60 to 47 patreon is 10.
so from 15 to 10 adsense which is like
you know
youtube paying us basically for the ads
to play is that 26.5
and yeah from up from 15 yeah and of
that
22 percent or like 22 of that 26.5
is from our main channel and 4.5 of that
26.5 are from our gaming channels
our two gaming channels yeah from the
two gaming channels combined so it's
mostly the main channel yeah
and the whole brand new income source is
twitch at nine percent
um affiliate is one percent
yes that's a lot lower from a lot lower
wow
and merch is 4.5 so that's very similar
to the four percent it used to be and i
know if anyone goes through and adds
that up
we're going to be a little bit short
that's because they're like little
decimal places that i'd like you know i
don't want to go like
10.3 and 1.2
you know so it doesn't add up to 100.
generally
generally that's the percentages and um
that is interesting
i think i do think like because we
started i think the main things are we
started streaming and we started the
gaming channel
and just like our videos get a
significant
amount more views and it's interesting
because like that should that does also
raise the amount you can charge sponsors
but not as much it doesn't scale
linearly
as you grow as your views grow yeah
you actually charge less per view yeah
like you charge sponsors
based on cpm so like the cost of
every thousand views you expect a video
to get in the first
30 days and you average out your past 10
taking out any like
super high or super low performers and
that kind of gives you
how you charge your sponsors but we were
able to charge a much higher cpm
when our videos were getting like 50 000
views to 100 000 views
than we are now and that's you know
that's okay
that's totally fine but it's just an
interesting observation
whereas adsense like it isn't affected
the same way
yeah and adsense has actually gone up
because as
like our adsense cpm not just the total
amount like the cost
as youtube gets more data about us
our viewers and everything like that
they can give better
better targeted apps targeted ads for
for companies and more targeted ads they
can charge more for
so yeah so our adsense has become
significantly higher and our sponsor
percentage has been significantly lower
and maybe they trust our video and our
channel and our videos a little bit more
i think another thing is you know it's
been a year since we last looked at
those numbers we have a year's worth of
additional videos going in adsense
because that's the other thing
sponsorship
is a one-time payment that you get for
doing that video
then it's done adsense is trickling in
from your entire i think that's probably
one of the biggest videos
yeah so like the more videos you have
the more adsense you're getting
kind of passively from all those past
videos it's interesting any one video
like is not making much
but when you have 160 however many
videos we have right now
it does add up more so i think that's a
big part of it too
yeah so yeah yes
so i think that like especially in the
beginning sponsors are super important
it was literally the thing that led us
create our jobs
yeah and and um as you grow you can
diversify and and you know twitch
is a good example of us moving into a
brand new platform and creating a
certain percentage of our income
that just didn't exist before um
so we got a few questions about how much
we charge for i kind of went into like
the cpm
it does range um but that's typically
how people
do it typically people are going to be
in the like
depending on how big you are and again
the bigger you are the lower cpm you're
charging but it's going to be like
i don't know 15 or 20 cpm up till like
45 cpm and it it's just
well also there's so much that goes into
it a lot of it also depends
on yeah like your industry and your
industry
how niche you are because the more niche
you are like if you
are reviewing tumblers and a tumbler
company
wants to pay you they're like they have
a direct link to an audience interested
in
but also certain niches have you know
better or worse chances of getting
higher or lower rates so it depends so
much also
i think that like how you know whether
it's purchasing stuff yeah
yeah and how you know if it's fair or
not is you basically reach out to other
content creators you meet them
you kind of compare notes um and then
also with enough offers coming in
you see what is off on the high end or
the low end
and you know when it's like a really
good deal for you or you know when
you're getting ripped off so it's just
yeah so it's kind of hard to know yeah
in the beginning
and there are some of those industry
standard rates like caitlin was talking
about with the cpm
um but that's like the rate i gave is so
wide it's so huge
people even outside yeah and it depends
a lot on like
you know how good your audience is and
also how cool that sponsor is
if that sponsor can go to anyone and say
like here's a couple bucks
you know do an ad and they're like oh my
gosh this
this cool company sponsored me you know
it's like how
desirable is the ad to um to advertise
also that's why sometimes some of these
companies that approach
you that you're like i don't know but
they're offering you so much money
they have to offer that much money
because no one wants to do deals with
them
you know sometimes i mean also i think
just like
maybe they're offering i think a lot
more frequently is they're offering that
much money
because they want a lot more from you
they want a lot more control
yeah and so that's the thing too is like
like our highest paying sponsors are
also the ones that want more control
which is
why those sponsors are much more rare
for us
because like it's like
you know if if their vision aligns with
our vision
and like they're cool with the things we
want to do
then it's okay because they're not
actually changing very much
but then some sponsors if if the idea
they have is totally different
than what we would want to do or they
would want a bunch of changes
then it's just not worth it we won't do
it so those sponsors are super rare yeah
um and i think how do you we got a
question how do you go about raising
rates with reoccurring sponsors
we just keep track of all of our metrics
and we have spreadsheets
and we have like you know and we just do
it just like any other business
negotiation it's like look we've grown
this much our views have gone this much
the link tracker that you guys are using
is like doing this and
you know then they they negotiate back
and forth but like you know
and most of the recurring ones we sign
up for like three months at a time
or four months at a time or six months
at a time or a year at a time so
we're not gonna like you know obviously
we're not renegotiating mid-contract and
sometimes if it's only been a few months
we won't
but like if it's been enough time that
like our numbers
have increased significantly we will
renegotiate
yeah um and sometimes they're cold and
sometimes they're kind of pushed back so
yeah um and that's another thing that
affects price are they a one-off that's
never going to come back again or are
they long-term
we're getting into the weeds wow i
wonder what people will think of this
podcast
these are their questions speaking of
interesting exciting things let's talk
about
tax from elizabeth elizabeth in this
um being self-employed how do you sort
out your taxes does receiving
sponsorships complicate how you file i
mean our taxes are complicated
because we have a bunch of different
income sources and because we are
self-employed
working with sponsors does not end like
that in itself is not a complication no
i mean you
you file your w and i and they send you
your 1099
you collect them all and and what have
you i think the thing that's most
complicated about being
like you know content creation is if you
are selling your own merch
state sales physical products physical
products oh physical products
are where it gets complicated that's so
complicated so we're not going to get
into the weeds about that because it has
nothing to do with sponsorships
but sponsorships don't um complicated
anything
any more than anything else i think we
got through all of the collections uh
the questions that we
uh collected like these are the most
common and upvoted questions that we
collected there probably were a lot more
yeah there's a lot more but it's been an
hour and eight minutes so shall we move
on to
thing of the week yes
i was going to ask you any like closing
thoughts on sponsors
oh no
no i mean i don't know i feel like we
talked a lot about a lot about it
yeah we we didn't talk about do you have
any closing thoughts before we talk
about a thing of the week i'm not going
to play the thing of the week music
again but
i think i think i'm very proud of us for
the
for the path that we walk trying to
create
fun ads for our audience trying to
create honest and positive you know
uh experiences for uh the brands that we
work for
and also we often have a lot of fun
making our own abs
i love doing funny skits yeah and like
dressing up like there was one recently
where like
i was i was in like full conspiracy
theory
mode with like a disheveled robe and
stuff where like any time we do like the
alien costumes
i think honestly like that the ads have
what's been
the those are the trigger that got us
into doing the skits
and stuff yeah so i i'm just i'm just uh
in closing i'm gonna say i'm proud of us
for navigating this tricky road
i feel like we're doing a pretty good
job i feel like we've developed a fun
style like a fun way of doing
sponsorships just want to like
acknowledge a win
good win baby we do get a lot of
comments saying like oh your ads are the
only ones that i don't skip and
like people mentioning funny moments
from the ad
specifically so i feel like that's a win
and i hope you guys know
that we don't take you guys and your
eyeballs
for granted we put a lot of thought and
time into what sponsors we choose
how we do the ad and and all of that
jobs it's like a way to make each one
uniquely funny in some way it's a long
time
it is a lot of work we'd have a lot more
hours in the week if we didn't do
sponsorship hope it shows that we care
and now
it is time for thing of the week i'm not
going to play the music again though
we've already played for it okay my
thing of the week is the thing that i've
had in my hands
for the whole podcast it's it's so cute
and it's
the weight of it feels good what is this
this is a terabyte hard drive
and you can get um something of the same
size
the two terabytes do you want to save it
for that for those of you guys who can't
see it it's the size of my nose
that's a very interesting comparison
yeah it's about like two and a half
inches by an inch yeah it's it's tiny
this tiny it's aluminum
it's usbc you just plug that in boom
and uh what is like the the brand of the
title because i know we'll we'll always
have a link to the thing of the week but
it might help this uh sabrient and it's
their
rocket nano hashtag not sponsored
not sponsored and i've only used it for
a short amount of time
but it's nice just having this in my bag
it's nice having a
tarot byte hard drive it's
like is this a hard drive or is this
like a big flash drive
i don't know what's the difference
anymore it's so tiny
i remember when like a terabyte used to
be like
yeah and it's like a gigabyte a second
i mean i'm just nerding out and i think
that like i'm like
showing my age or something like that
like being like oh my gosh usb
usbc you can plug it both ways how
convenient and
that powers it and there's data remember
when there used to be two cables one for
power one for data
back in my day terabyte hard drives use
a carry in a backpack
well it's funny i was gonna bring that
baby backpack but like one thing you
guys
might have gathered from evan over all
of his recommendations or just seeing
his technology pop up here and there and
video i love tiny things everyone loves
tiny things
you got two baby computers you got this
baby terabyte
you got baby backpack you have all these
little things and you
you love having your like technology go
bag i love having like yeah everything i
need for like
various things with me in my in like a
little grab bag
it's so cool um update on the gpd win
max
she's doing it really well that's my
best gaming that's my gaming baby
computer
yeah that was your thing of the week
last time right yeah i should do it i
should do a technology review channel
[Laughter]
okay my thing of the week is a movie we
watched yes we watched a movie everyone
we did it was called mary and the
witch's flower it's an anime movie
that's great and so
a bunch of the people from studio ghibli
which is like
but shut down which is that the shutdown
was just very sad but you know
made a huge amount of amazing movies
it's like spirited away and totoro and
like
a bunch of amazing animals moving
castles moving castle
like a bunch of the classics um a lot of
the people from that studio
reformed into a new studio and the name
of it is like
escaping me right now but their first
full-length movie they've put out
is mary and the witch's flower and it's
totally like
the vibes the vibes are so good so feel
good but and the story is kind of like
if you crossed a little bit of harry
potter with a little bit of spirited
away and it's very fantastical
and it's just great there's oh my gosh
there's
there's two cats in there two cat
characters and one of them is a little
black cat named tib
and tib like tiffany's attitude yeah tim
is jew like i love tim's attitude he was
my favorite character
even though he never spoke because he is
a cat but just like the expressions i
was just like standing for tim the whole
time
it's so interesting i was reading one
review and they're like you know
there's there's too many things that
like seem like they're pulled straight
from other ghibli movies like they
should have done something new and i'm
like no
i like them they had lots of like little
callbacks little like
it was almost like little easter eggs of
like similar
like i don't know i i felt very like at
home
like i felt like i was still in the
ghibli universe which is what i want
went into it
i i want i want more of that yeah do
more like it was like more of the same
thing in a good way i just want more
yeah
take your time i know that those videos
take a long time but please make more
you're speaking directly to the studio
now yes yes yes
so as always we will have links to both
of our thing of the weeks in the
description yeah wow that that i'm
surprised honestly that we fit all of
that into
something it was dense it was a lot it
was dense i hope it was interesting
we tried to spill as much tea as we
could without breaking any nda's
spilling beans oh yeah we spilled the
beans without breaking any ndas or
getting too specific
yeah um uh bye
oh no no wait wait before you go before
you go you need you need to prank
everyone um so leave us reviews
um wherever you can relieve reviews for
the podcast because we want this to go
to number one
in in one in a chart i think we're in
the leisure category caitlin
should we bring the leisure i don't know
i don't know it's hard to categorize the
podcast
we're like we just talk about ourselves
and stuff yeah we're
also talking about ourselves
anyways we're like get us in the rink so
we can confuse people that's the best
idea because if uh people don't already
know our channel and they see our
podcasts in the ranks they're going to
be very confused about why these two
people have a podcast and why they're
talking about
random stuff so yeah that's the prank
just to explain it
you know it's a good prank when you have
to explain it yes yes see you next time
bye
[Laughter]
[Music]